and what about Black Adam I'm always is  that gonna happen is it gonna happen in  the near future definitely gonna happen  sure we've had great conversations well  you know with Geoff Johns and everybody  over to see it it's an exciting time for  DC right now because the goal is to  really build out the goal is always to  build out the DC universe right but  they're doing theirs there is how can I  put this there they're in a process now  where they are building out really  nicely right with a lot of the movies  that they have coming out and we have a  really cool surprise for Black Adam I  can't reveal with where we will see  Black Adam actually being interested if  you for this matching on Superman one  fine day that's coming that's in the  cards  [Music]